it turns out that the Netflix comedy
special Chris Rock selective outrage was
selectively edited by the streamer but
it has nothing to do with censorship so
why did they choose to chop up a
much-hyped live event when Will Smith
slapped Chris Rock at the 2022 Oscar
ceremony the incident and immediately
became Infamous manifesting memes social
commentary and hot takes from every
corner of the internet following the
slap Smith publicly apologized to Chris
explained his actions and accepted his
10-year ban from the academy
a behavior was unacceptable
and I'm here whenever you're ready to
talk while Smith and his wife Jada
Pinkett Smith have been vocal about the
incident Rock was largely quiet until
now as a comedian it's only natural that
rock would break his silence on that
chaotic night doing the one thing he
knows best comedy the couple were a key
part of Rock's new Netflix stand-up
comedy special Chris Rock's selective
outrage after detailing his issues with
expensive yoga pants ruminating on
American politics and debating
controversial opinions Rock spent the
last minutes of his show calling out the
Smiths seeing as the world has been
waiting for the comedian's unfiltered
thoughts on the slab Netflix launched
the special with much fanfare making it
their very first live event to air
across the world while it was a largely
successful effort the comedian's
performance showed the difficulties of
performing live in front of millions
near the end of the special rock
delivered a series of jokes about both
Smith and Pinkett Smith which included a
flub where he confused Smith's 2015
Sports drama concussion for his 2022
slavery era emancipation in the live
stream Rock said years ago his wife said
I should quit the Oscars I shouldn't
host because her man didn't get
nominated for emancipation the biggest
piece of [__] ever no not emancipation I
[__] up the joke after the mix-up Rock
did that part of the joke over again she
said a me a grown ass man should quit
his job because her husband didn't get
nominated for concussion Brock was
referencing Jada Pinkett Smith
boycotting the Oscar ceremony during the
peak of the Oscar so white movement
despite Rock's quick correction Netflix
decided to edit the flub out of the
on-demand version of The Life program
according to the Hollywood Reporter
although the exact reasons for the cut
are unknown was it just an easy fix to
make so the special would have more
polish or was the streaming giant trying
to avoid the backlash they'd likely get
for rock roasting the historical slavery
drama even if it was by mistake well
Rock messed up the joke in a really
awkward way it reportedly still received
Applause during the original version of
the special The Hollywood Reporter
confirms that rock is aware of the
change and has worked with Netflix to
make the necessary edits viewers who
decide to watch The Comedy Special on
Netflix's official website will see a
disclaimer just below the set's title
which reads streamed live and edited the
special also no longer features the N
live logo on the right hand bottom
corner in the final edited version of
the special rock effortlessly Glides
through the joke never mentioning
emancipation some fans may be
disappointed that Netflix is undermining
the live and unfiltered aspect of the
special especially after making such an
event out of it it's unclear if Netflix
would have still edited the special in
any capacity if Rock hadn't flubbed his
own joke the publication also
highlighted how Chris Rock's selective
outrage had failed to land in the
streaming services worldwide rankings
even though it came in at seventh place
in the U.S Top 10 rankings
please